[Music]
we're happy to see that Dax is gonna be
on the ranch
so I say I'm just gonna claim it that
the women in their lives help foster
this because you and me'll up work so
well together that is like a wider
expression our hobbies do that that's
true but they but really they started
that I reckon comment yeah I think young
today fell in love and they've remained
friends and then I was just lucky enough
to work with Mila on Sarah Marshall than
Payne great friends and then that
contributed to bad moms but yes we love
it's a it's a very nice foursome yeah
and we have kids the same age they're
good people and I'm bummed that right
after I talked to you last week then Dax
like made news everywhere with his
podcast Ella the great interview with
Ellen and like he just made news
everywhere so good I know and it makes
me as his wife so excited because like
there's nothing he's never in a better
Lane than when he's talking to people he
likes to talk about vulnerable issues he
has a sense of intimacy when he talks to
you and I'm like oh that of course a
podcast it's that's what you should be
doing not that he shouldn't be
performing but he's exponentially happy
when he's talking to human being
[Music]
[Applause]